we are in the business of running people
for public office in order to change
public policy to do nothing more or less
than set the world free in our lifetime
the greatest nation in mankind's history
is on a suicide mission and we can try
to save it we can try to increase the
Liberty movement we can try to bring
more people on board you get people to
take baby steps towards you you don't
get them to eat the whole elephant all
at once that's not how politics works
they say I have some purity test like
like I think the libertarian nominee
should be a libertarian tonight's
resolution reads the libertarian party
should never again put up National
candidates whose views are similar to
those of Gary Johnson and bill weld
arguing for the affirmative Dave Smith
Dave please come to the stage for the
negative Nicks our walk Nick please come
to the stage
Jane Jane please close the voting all
right thank you guys very much that
great job Rob Bernstein I was in cried
every NIMBY funny in front of people
before so that was unbelievable also
he's fired if anyone wants to be my new
co-host
that's tight no jokes about me
all right in all seriousness it is it is
an honor to be here tonight
I love the Soho forum it's an honor to
step into the ring and it's genuinely a
privilege to be on stage with somebody
who I have so much respect for who I've
learned so much from and it's also cool
that Knicks our walk is here that's it
I'm done all right I'm sorry start off
with one and now I move on I actually I
actually am very thankful that Nick is
here I think this is a very important
topic that gets right at the core of
what we are all doing here like what are
we doing as libertarians what is our
reason for being and what is the plan
here and I this is a very serious topic
to me I became a libertarian about 11
years ago I was a child of the Ron Paul
movement and like many people here when
I was introduced to these ideas they
changed my life I immediately when like
so many of you when these ideas click
with you you I was like I'm gonna be a
soldier in the Liberty movement for the
rest of my life and that's what I'm
doing and that's what I will continue to
do that's what I care about you know I
heard Nick recently I was watching a
video of his when he was doing a debate
for the lp chairmanship and he said as
the chair of the LP the party is
paramount I don't look at things that
way I will tell you right now I don't
care about the Libertarian Party I don't
care about it at all
I don't care how many votes they get I
don't care how much fundraising they get
I definitely don't care if Nick's able
to work out a $75 an hour deal from them
okay that doesn't mean anything to me
I'm just saying what I care about what's
paramount to me is liberty I care about
the Liberty movement I care about the
philosophy of libertarianism the most
beautiful brilliant political philosophy
ever devised by man I care about the
actually seeing Liberty in real people's
lives now just to be clear I don't have
to go off on this to you people but the
philosophy of libertarianism is the
philosophy of peace it's the philosophy
of prosperity and as I've come more and
more to realize it's the philosophy of
civilization I mean what better
describes civilized behavior than the
non-aggression principle and respect for
private property rights it's what you
would teach your three-year-old
as they go into the world don't hit
other people and don't take their stuff
and you know we have to and this is why
when you get to the debate resolution
the question is what we should do and
that really gets to the core of what you
believe and what you think we're trying
to do here look we need to recognize the
the moment that we are living in right
now okay we are this country is on a
goddamn suicide mission I'm not being
hyperbolic we're on a [ __ ] suicide
mission right now 20-plus trillion
dollars in debt not to mention the
unfunded liabilities and the public
sector Union you know pensions which
make that look like nothing we a warfare
state that can't find the conflict that
doesn't want to get bogged down in we've
got an economy that's regulated every
nook and cranny a prison industrial
complex and a police state that would
make Adolf Hitler and Joseph Stalin
impressed I know listen I know there's
some of you guys who think I'm like a
little bit too radical tell me what I'm
wrong what what am I wrong about and
what I just said you think that Joseph
Stalin and Adolf Hitler wouldn't look at
what we have and go god damn they gave
the Department of Education a SWAT team
these bastards are good okay that is the
moment we are living in right now all
right
and we libertarians have the philosophy
that has the answers
for pretty much every one of these
problems I mean I'm not saying we can
solve everything but we pretty much know
what to do with all of this stuff okay
so what do we want to do you want to
take a shot you want to try to actually
do something that might make a
difference in this situation or do you
want to sit around you know I I watched
these left-libertarians debating age of
consent laws i watch the chairman of the
LP using these despicable social justice
warrior tactics against the people who
spread liberty the most and it's like
what do you guys want to do here the
nation the greatest nation in mankind's
history is on a suicide mission and we
can try to save it we can try to
increase the Liberty movement we can try
to bring more people on board what what
do you want to do you know I was
listening to um to the reason podcast in
preparation for this debate I was
listening the reason podcast and they
had a bill weld on at Freedom Fest last
year I made it through the whole thing
and by the way I love Nick and Matt I
love both of those guys but there was
one point where they're talking to bill
weld and they have this false dynamic
where they go you know there's a lot of
these like anarchists out there who want
a candidate who can change 1 million
people's minds and then there's like the
pragmatic candidate like bill weld who's
trying to get 70 million votes
that's pragmatic the idea that bill weld
will get 70 million votes I mean are you
kidding me right now and then and then
Nick Gillespie who I love but he says
you know there are these anarchists who
their whole thing is they want to die on
the hill of we need to privatize the
sidewalks look man that's not the hill
I'm trying to die on the hill I'm trying
to die on is we need to end the wars and
end the Fed and that's what our
candidates should be saying and I have I
will gladly die on that hill now look if
you really look there is no there's no
conflict between should we win 70
million votes or should we try to
convert another million people we will
never win 70 million votes unless we
convert another
million people and then another million
people after that and another million
people after that that's our only choice
the only question that matters to
libertarians as far as national
candidates goes is who can convert more
people that's it if we get votes without
converting anyone then what have we won
nothing okay so what are we doing here
do you want it you want to convert more
people well I don't know you're a
libertarian and you want to convert more
people gee I wonder what we should look
to when was the last time anyone
converted a lot of people to
libertarianism and we all know the
answer I don't care what you think of
him it was the great Ron Paul
she was the guy who converted people
every one of you knows this you don't
have to love Ron Paul you don't have to
agree with him on everything but he
converted people to this movement in a
way that no one else in my lifetime has
so why don't we try to learn from that
what did he do he was courageous
he was principled he stood up in 2007 in
george w bush's republican party and
said the bravest thing you could
possibly say you guys remembered the
George W Bush administration or the
terrorists are wrong and the troops are
the good guys he went yeah not so much
actually the troops are kind of the bad
guys in this fight and the terrorists
are kind of acting the way any of us
would if someone did that to them now
that was courage that converted me it
converted a lot of you that Ron Paul
there's a quote from Ron Paul when they
asked him they asked Ron Paul what his
campaign was about he said I would sum
up my foreign policy as the following I
don't want to run the world I don't know
how to run the world the Constitution
doesn't give me the authority to run the
world we ought to mind our own business
and I would sum up my domestic policy as
the following I don't want to run your
life I don't know how to run your life
the Constitution doesn't give me the
authority to run your life we ought to
respect individual liberty in this
country that was Ron Paul's message now
to be fair Gary Johnson I saw him on TV
just a few months ago and he said and I
quote I think the system could be
tweaked to make a
more fair that's that's what we're going
with you know something you have to
understand about the moment we live in
right now and libertarians if we do not
record on grapple with this we do this
at our own cost there is an insurrection
going on against the center that's
what's happening in politics right now
it's been building for years do you guys
know that movie loose change the the
documentary that said that the
government was that 9/11 was an inside
job but I'm not I don't agree with that
movie that's not the point I'm making
but it was viewed like over a hundred
million times the idea that the
government was responsible for 9/11 was
something a lot of people in this
country were willing to accept be at
least be intrigued by that that then
Barack Hussein Obama got elected Barack
Hussein Obama ran against Hillary
Clinton and John McCain the two most
centrist candidates you could imagine
and he won then you had the Tea Party
movement the Occupy movement the Ron
Paul campaign of 2008 the Ron Paul
campaign in 2012 the Bernie Sanders
campaign of 2016 and oh yeah Donald
Trump's the president I don't know if
you noticed what's going on right now
but there is a war on the center there
is there's a revulsion against the
center and by the way that's a good
thing you know so often libertarians we
criticize the populist left the aoc the
populist right the Steve Bannon but the
the message of CNN is basically a you
know well I don't think we need to go as
far as aoc we definitely don't want to
go with Bannon let's just meet in the
middle with Hillary Clinton and Lindsey
Graham the blood-soaked monsters who put
us on this path to national suicide you
know we may have our problems with
populism
I certainly do I've spent a lot of time
on my podcast disagreeing with that but
can you relate to it a little can any
libertarian honestly say I don't know
why you'd have a problem with the elites
they've only mismanaged everything for
the last hundred years
so obviously the role of
libertarian it's so it's so clear the
message that we do is it you know no
this is what the libertarian party in
2016 goes I know you guys are
anti-establishment you hate the center
we're the ones who really hate the
center we've been talking about this
forever we don't need a go populist left
or populist right we don't need to
embrace neo Marxism or neo-fascism these
disastrous movements from the 20th
century turns out the answer is pretty
much our bill of rights our story our
history embrace freedom that's the
answer and what did the Libertarian
Party do they had this huge opportunity
the biggest opportunity for Liberty we
could have possibly imagined we would
have killed in the Ron Paul days we
would have killed for an hour CNN Town
Hall they were pretending that guy
didn't exist and what did we do when we
got the message well we're we're a
couple of Republican governors who were
elected in blue states fiscal
conservatives and socially liberal
basically they said come back to the
center that's what they said the worst
message you could have possibly had now
let me just quickly cuz I'm gonna go too
long here the the views that Gary
Johnson and bill weld had Gary Johnson
and Bill weld by the way that's what the
resolution states so let me just go let
make this point I'm not gonna point out
you know I may say some views of theirs
that I don't like maybe Nick comes up
and says some views of theirs that he
thinks are good look let me put it this
way let's say I found you a candidate
for the Libertarian Party
I said he's um you know he supports free
trade he's for lowering lowering tax
rates and he was for gay marriage way
back in 2004 you guys like him as a
candidate for the LP okay your
candidates Dick Cheney do you think
that's a good candidate for the LP or
would you go well no because he
instituted torture so that's
disqualifying it doesn't matter how good
you were on three other issue but he
wasn't even that good but whatever they
it doesn't matter so what I'm gonna
point to right now are disqualifying
views that gary johnson and bill weld
had and despite what Nick's gonna say
this campaign was a failure it was a
failure the Libertarian Party has less
members if if I get less than five times
the amount of members the LP has on one
podcast I start rethinking what I'm
doing with my career okay that's the
goddamn truth it's a fact here are the
views Gary and I'll get into more of
them later because I'm already running
long okay Gary Johnson's view that is
disqualifying his view was that bill
weld should be his VP disqualifying okay
and by the way he said they were gonna
govern as a partnership
this was their pitch they were gonna
govern as a partnership with one staff
so we were putting bill weld as the
nominee for the liberty' you know a lot
of people accuse me who don't agree with
me on this topic and I would just ask
some of you guys they say I have some
purity test like like I think the
libertarian nominee should be a
libertarian that's my purity test I
don't think they should be a Warhawk by
the way bill weld was a [ __ ] lobbyist
for Raytheon didn't you guys know that
yeah bill weld a lobbyist for a weapons
company is that yeah I know it's a
purity test I don't think we should put
that guy up
the guy who vouched for Hillary Clinton
voucher bill weld by the way I'm a
professional stand-up comedian bill weld
said I vouch that Hillary Clinton is an
honest person funnier than anything I've
put out there never once
that's what bill weld said this is a guy
who supported not only the Fed but the
dual mandate supported the war in Iraq
in 2016 he endorsed Kasich that was who
he was by the way I you know Nick was
like oh well you know I think bill weld
coming over to the libertarian party
made didn't make the libertarian party
any more establishment it made Bill
Wells more libertarian nothing could be
further from the truth
it made the Libertarian Party more
establishment because they nominated
bill weld and did it make bill weld more
libertarian he bailed as soon as he was
done using you guys you guys made you
made fools of you guys okay
listen and I'm gonna end this on a quote
from somebody who will say this better
than I ever could and then I'll wrap up
very quickly and that is the quote from
the great heroic and courageous Tom
woods
[Applause]
we libertarians are the inheritors of an
exceptionally venerable tradition of
ideas that is noble and beautiful and
that carries with it a grave
responsibility we must be true to that
inheritance enough putting people to
sleep already it's time we finally woke
them up thank you
[Applause]
it's all work you got an extra half
minute oh so 15 minutes neck thank you
to Jean thank you to Dave thank you to
so whole forum thank you to all of you
for coming out here I want to start out
by saying I recognize that I am pushing
a rock uphill I did enough trials to
understand when I'm being hometown and
Dave spent a lot more time in this room
than I have and that's okay where I'm a
little confused as we had a proposition
I'm pretty sure it was that we shouldn't
nominate anyone with views like gary
johnson or bill weld again and the only
disqualifying views i heard from the
affirmative were that gary johnson
wanted bill weld to be the vp bill weld
thought Hillary Clinton was an honest
person and bill weld used to be a
lobbyist for Raytheon so perhaps during
the rebuttal time mr. Smith will
continue with more views that he thinks
are disqualifying and put some meat on
the proposition be that as it may there
are some things that he said about how
the ideas clicked with him during the
Ron Paul campaign and I lived through
that too I actually voted for Ron Paul
in a Maryland primary where it really
doesn't matter because I was excited
about what he had the opportunity to do
as many of you know Ron Paul was our
candidate in 1988 and I find that a lot
of people in the Libertarian Party are
people who've had that epiphany
something has clicked for you some
problem that the government has done has
rubbed you the wrong way to the point
where the scales came off your eyes and
you realize that the government controls
us in so many ways not just the one that
is the problem you start to see the
world in a different way from everybody
else
it makes you special it makes you
libertarian it makes you rare there
aren't a lot of
as Dave so aptly points out the
libertarian party's paid membership is
plus or minus fifteen thousand people
that pay dues the number of partisan
registered libertarians in the United
States and states that have registration
by party it's roughly six hundred
thousand in a country of a few hundred
million not everybody thinks like us and
so the question comes as a political
party is the only piece of the Liberty
movement that goes out into the arena
and actually gets our hands dirty on the
debate stage that fights with
establishment politicians that puts our
ideas out there what is the best
strategy for us because we are not in
the educating business we are not in the
think-tank business we are not in the
business of creating a different culture
we are not just what we're going through
businesses in the podcasting business
although I hear some people are and it's
apparently very lucrative we are in the
business of running people for public
office in order to change public policy
to do nothing more or less than set the
world free in our lifetime and that game
is different from every other game and
has to be played according to the rules
of that game because they keep score
different there now
Dave talks about how he would rather
change 1 million Minds than win 70
million votes that's a great plan that's
a good idea but it came right after Dave
said he doesn't really care about the
Libertarian Party because Dave doesn't
care about politics and a lot of
libertarians don't care about politics
but politics is what the party does and
I want to go over some stats for you
because they're important because facts
matter and facts don't care about Dave's
feelings
the fact is the Libertarian Party has
tried what Dave thinks I think Dave
would agree with me that Ron Paul would
be the ideal libertarian presidential
candidate wouldn't you Dave Ron Paul was
the libertarian presidential candidate
in the year 1988 and Ron Paul in 1988
raised two million dollars which is
quite a bit in 1988 and he got four
hundred and thirty thousand votes for
president half a percent of the popular
vote by contrast Gary Johnson in 2012
when he didn't have bill weld got 1.3
million votes hit one percent for the
first time since ed Clark in 1980 and he
raised 2.5 million dollars so a similar
amount in nominal dollars to Ron Paul in
1988 a significantly smaller amount in
real dollars because of the Fed and
inflation and he got more than basically
twice as many votes so just on the facts
we know the difference between running
Gary Johnson and running Ron Paul and
it's roughly two times as good of a
result now if you don't care about the
votes that's fine you don't care about
the votes but then I asked what is the
proposition we're talking about what a
political party should do and what do
political parties do they run candidates
and they get votes in 2016 where the
only change to the ticket is a different
vice presidential nominee it's still
Gary Johnson at the top but it's Bill
weld at the bottom Gary Johnson got four
and a half million votes three point
three percent of the general election
popular vote covered the spread between
the winner and the loser for the first
time in Libertarian Party history and
they did that raising twelve million
dollars a nearly fivefold increase from
the last election before bill weld was
on the ticket
now I don't think it's a good thing to
be a lobbyist for Raytheon it's not work
I would take although I'm an attorney
and I've represented some people that
probably you guys wouldn't like so I
have a little bit different perspective
on it I want to talk about one of the
views that he did actually discuss and I
want to start by saying there are many
different kinds of libertarians in the
world there are libertarians that
prioritize property rights money foreign
intervention the drug war criminal
justice reform gay rights there's a
there's a ton of different kinds of
libertarians in fact if you have three
libertarians in a room the only thing
they'll agree with you is that there's
only one libertarian in the room and
it's them this is the nature we're a
fractious people but we're good people
in our party's history we've actually
done those studies we've looked at where
do people come from how do you get to
the libertarian party like there's no
one path there's no no one there's no
wrong way to eat a Reese's right as long
as you get there it's okay
roughly a third of people who are part
of the Libertarian Party were formerly
Republicans or conservatives they come
from that place they realize that
Republicans aren't really conservative
never are gonna be and that Republicans
actually hate libertarians and they
decide you know why give up all the
pretending just be a libertarian roughly
1/3 our former Democrats are
progressives they realize that the
Democratic Party doesn't really care
about equality and human rights that in
fact what they care about is it's a
different set of lobbyists that they
would like to give favors to and they're
like why to bother pretending the party
apparatus is just gonna make Hillary
Clinton the nominee anyway I might as
well become a libertarian and roughly a
third come from having never been
anything or been independent or just
don't like politics generally and we
seem like the most apolitical political
party we are the 7up of political
parties we are the on Cola and so they
come to us because they're like this is
as close as I can get as an anarchist or
an independent to saying you know when
you ask me who do I want to vote for my
answer is this that's my answer
these are people who by voting for them
I get to say that to people in a way
that they can understand because as
somebody once told me some politicians
are dumb some politicians are corrupt
but every single one of them knows how
to count and they can count all the
votes that they get they can count all
the votes that they didn't get and they
know exactly how many votes the
Libertarians got that is the strongest
message people can send in a voting
booth because it says you told me that
this person's the devil or this person's
the devil and I denied your entire frame
I voted for what I wanted instead of
what you wanted me to be afraid of I'm
stronger than you I'm more principled
than you I know what I want and
goddammit I'm gonna get it that's why
the Libertarian Party exists and the
number of votes we get determines the
amplitude of that message if you want to
send a message to whoever wins the
presidency you better well get a ton of
votes because that's what scares him do
you think that the president let john
bolton go because he wanted to know he
hired the guy he's dumb like that he let
him go because it was finally unpopular
enough for him to have him there that's
libertarians that push that way it's
libertarians that push against the Jeff
Sessions of the world
it's libertarians who want something
different but you have to have the
numbers to make the persuasive argument
because they aren't able to be
rationally dealt with politicians are
not necessarily the most moral people in
the world and so you have to help them
feel the heat because they may not be
able to see the light now I want to talk
specifically about the interview with
Rachel Maddow that Dave talks about in
which bill weld vouched for the
character of the woman that he worked
with when he was counsel for the Senate
remember I always said a third of
libertarians come from the left and a
third come from the right and a third
come from the middle so if you go
through a room of libertarians and you
gun to your head who would you rather
win the 2016 election a third of them
are gonna say Hillary Clinton a third of
them are gonna say Donald Trump and a
third of them are gonna give the right
answer which Gary Johnson gave pull the
trigger it's not a good idea
to express your preferences when you're
a candidate because a third of the party
is gonna be mad at you for that and
apparently a third of the party still is
mad at him for that three years later
after he lost I mean what more
punishment do you want for bill weld
other than the fact that his strategy
didn't work but pushing aside from that
you know there's a lot of different ways
to be a libertarian there are really
great libertarians like Walter Bloch who
decided that somehow it was more
libertarian to support Donald Trump than
it was to support Gary Johnson I
disagree with that but I'm not gonna say
Walter Bloks not a libertarian Murray
Rothbard thought it would be libertarian
to support Richard Nixon I'm a little
bit more touchy about that but you know
Murray Rothbard is dead and can't defend
himself so I'm gonna say he's still a
libertarian libertarians make bad
choices the libertarian platform has a
lot of planks in it there's roughly 30
some planks in libertarian platform and
every presidential candidate no matter
what is going to deviate from some of
those planks and until or unless the
libertarian party says these planks are
more important than those planks those
are personal opinions that every party
member has every one of us came to this
for our own reasons some of us it's guns
some of us like Rob it's it's drugs some
of its it's war some of its the Fed if
your issue is the one that the candidate
doesn't agree on you're going to think
that person's not a libertarian but if
the issue the candidate doesn't agree on
is one that you don't care about you're
gonna be like yeah he's libertarian he
just not libertine on everything who
cares right it's all about your
perspective there's no accounting for
taste and part of the thing about having
a political party is political parties
are made up of the people who show up a
political party is not a fixed thing it
is not systemic
as you know people have pointed out to
me and apparently there's some caucus
within the party that's really
aggressively trying to work on this if
you can get enough people to go to the
convention you can change the entire
direction of a party I was expecting
more of a clap for that come on guys
believe in yourselves um so what that
means is if you throw rocks from the
sidelines but you never get involved
you're probably gonna get ignored the
funny thing is people tell me all the
time you shouldn't have nominated Garry
Johnson you shouldn't have nominated
bill weld I don't get to nominate
anybody I've got one delegate vote at
convention one and I don't usually tell
people who I vote for it's not worth it
there are over a thousand people who
come from from libertarian parties
around the country who have been party
members for decades who come to
convention and they work very hard to
try and pick the candidate who has the
best balance of being a pure libertarian
message and having a high enough profile
to get that message out to people and
that balancing act is so important
because we have two back-to-back
candidates that show what happens when
you get out of balance in 2004 Michael
Bennett was the nominee probably the
hardest core purist libertarian you have
ever seen who has ever been at the top
of our ticket including Ron Paul Michael
Bednarik didn't have a driver's license
that's how intense this guy was and he
got 0.3 percent of the vote and right
after that the pendulum shifted the
other way and we got a former
congressman Bob Barr who is not very
pure in his libertarian messaging
definitely out of driver's license and
he got like 0.4 percent of the vote
going either side doesn't work the last
thing I want to tell you about is this
is the important part the Johnson got
four and a half million votes right
there are roughly 600,000 registered
libertarians partisan registered
libertarians
that means that at a minimum at a
minimum even if every registered
libertarian voted 87 percent of
Johnson's voters were not libertarian
yet those are the people that we talk to
when we run for office and if we don't
talk to those people in language they
can understand and get those votes we
don't get ballot access for every other
Libertarian candidate all around the
country who runs for state and local
office so that we can continue to do
this work and eventually set the world
free in our lifetime my five minutes of
rebuttal for you today all right I don't
know where to start okay
the idea that Ron Paul in 1988 didn't
get as many votes as Gary Johnson did
today yes he also didn't inherit the ron
paul movement from 2008 and 2012 he also
wasn't running he wasn't running against
the two most hated candidates in the
history of the world by the way Ross
Perot got like close to 20 million votes
running against the charismatic Bill
Clinton and the war hero George HW Bush
but you're so quick to accept this as a
victory because Gary Johnson guys have
votes you know you said something at the
end there that really is the most
important point and you take it in the
exact wrong direction
did you know 87 percent of the people
who voted for Gary Johnson aren't even
libertarians yeah and they're still not
that's the whole point that's why the
votes don't mean anything listen so we
got more votes so this is your point we
got more but look Gary Johnson got more
votes than Ron Paul did in 2012 let me
ask you something every one of you do
you think the Liberty movement is doing
better in 2019 than it was in 2013
do you really are you out of your
freaking minds if you think it's doing
better today go to a YouTube video in
2013 and look at the comments we owned
them right now libertarianism is
considered a joke and it's because it
kind of is because we put a candidate up
Gary Johnson who did ridiculous stuff
couldn't
remember names and places and get was I
mean the whole thing was just absurd now
look I I don't know what else to rebut
if you're gonna say that I didn't give
enough views I'm sorry I thought for a
roomful of libertarians being pro war
and pro fed was enough to be
disqualifying if you'd like me to
continue I mean we could do another hour
of views that were disqualifying and the
point I was making with with bill weld
saying he it's not that he preferred
Hillary Clinton to Donald Trump I'm not
that's not the point at all let me be
very precise about this it's why he
preferred Hillary Clinton to Donald
Trump bill weld said when the
Libertarian Party got what all of us
were anza prompt all supporters would
have dreamed of getting an hour on CNN
and they asked him what he thinks about
Hillary Clinton
he said we disagree on some economic
issues but she's a good person that's
what she's that's what he said now
forget good person you know whatever I
mean sure she's a good person who
happened to be friends with you know
Jeffrey Epstein the child pedophile and
sure her husband's a sexual predator and
sure her best friend's husband's also a
sexual predator but I'm sure she's like
a great person who just happens to hang
out with a lot of pedophiles anyway
forget that libertarians what's our
problem with Hillary Clinton
if you don't lead with Libya Iraq Yemen
Syria millions of corpses millions of
dead people trillions wasted destroyed
nations that's our problem she said his
problem we disagree on some economic
issues by the way bill weld also said of
the bush cheney administration they're
doing a great job globally but I
disagree on their social issues and he
said on that Rachel Maddow show that
you're talking about and this is 2016
candidate Trump he said Donald Trump I'm
not gonna act like these two are equal
Donald Trump's foreign policy puts him
in a class all by himself of danger
Donald Trump saying we should end these
work now of course Donald Trump right
now should be in pre impeached and tried
for war crimes for what he's doing in
Yemen but that's not what he ran on what
he ran on was ending the stuff and
that's what bill weld objected to it's
not that you
Hillary Clinton it's why you chose her
that's the whole point of this okay and
if the Libertarian Party doesn't want to
be the anti-war party please just
disband already who cares
we've killed millions of people we are
competing with Hitler in the number of
deaths we have right now it's borderline
genocide what we've done to the middle
east if you're not against that after
the millions dead the trillions wasted
nations destroyed what is the point of
view now by the way like I said I'm a
soldier in the Liberty movement I'm
happy to support the libertarian party
if it's actually supporting the Liberty
movement then fine I'm down to look
Michael hice and the Mises caucus guys
he came out he said look all he said was
I'm a soldier in this Liberty movement I
want to reignite the Ron Paul revolution
we're starting this thing Tom Woods is
on board and I went I'm in that's all it
took I'm in I'm a soldier I'm ready for
anybody to lead but you have to be
anti-war anti fed those are my own only
qualifiers
if whoever you're looking at today if
Justin Amash comes over if he's the guy
if he wants to run an anti-war anti fed
campaign I'll get on board with that one
that's all I care about in this moment
of populist uprising is that has there
ever been a better time to be anti fed
to insert that into the conversation
than now Gary Johnson said he rejects
the dual mandate and they should only
have the monetary policy bill weld
supported the dual mandate that is
disqualifying Thanks
my master Nick 15 seconds I gotta give
Dave props everybody knows to go a
little over when you do debate let's
just start from the backend you know the
dual mandate the full employment low
inflation to a mandate of the Federal
Reserve I do I prefer somebody who's
anti Fed sure does anybody outside the
Libertarian Party or the Liberty
movement give a [ __ ]
absolutely not absolutely not
they don't care and this is what it
comes down to and this is really I think
the heart of the premise I think this is
the actual proposition that was unstated
perhaps is what do you want the
Libertarian Party to do do you want us
to go out and convince people to join
the club to become part of the movement
to wake up to pull the scales off their
eyes to decide that they really believe
in freedom for everything all the time
or do you want to go out and win votes
because if you want to go out and win
votes you have to win them from people
who are not libertarians again roughly
600,000 out of a country of 300 and some
million identify as libertarians but 10
times as many voted for the libertarian
presidential candidate ask yourself why
is that it's not because they said nice
things about Hillary Clinton it's not
because they supported the dual mandate
it's not because of anything baked the
cake Aleppo whatever it is it's not
because of any of the things that that
tick off libertarians about what they
did it's because for people who don't
have the scales off their eyes for
people who think when you tell them I
want you to live free that they're
already free go walk down the street
here in New York say hey I just want you
to live free everybody here seems to be
doing pretty good everybody seems to
like it they all think there
because they haven't run into the place
where government hurts them to the point
that it wakes them up they haven't had
the Ron Paul moment so the question is
do you not go for their votes until
they've woken up or do you get them to
vote for a libertarian
and maybe vote for a libertarian a
second time I guarantee you a lot of the
2016 Gary Johnson voters and the reason
that he did better the second time was
there were people who already voted for
him already liked him from 2012 or liked
him from when he was governor of New
Mexico you get people to take baby steps
towards you you don't get them to eat
the whole elephant all at once that's
not how politics works this waking
people up is a thing to be done one on
one by all of you when you talk to your
friends and co-workers you wake them up
to these ideas you get them to be as
indignant as you are about the fact that
anybody would support the Federal
Reserve but that's not the entry point
for most people for most people it's the
fact that the government has 22 trillion
dollars in debt which by the way if you
visit 22 trillion org the Libertarian
Party is the only political party
actually talking about this issue right
now they care about the fact that the
government is bankrupting their children
and their grandchildren they care about
the fact that the government is going to
send their kids overseas to die in
foreign wars and the Johnson weld ticket
was anti-war they were anti-war they
were hella more anti-war than any of
their opponents no matter what your
problems were with Gary Johnson and Bill
weld I guarantee you there was no other
option on your ballot that had so many
libertarian positions in one spot maybe
they had two or three that you didn't
like maybe they were ones that were
really important to you and it's
offensive maybe you hate Hillary Clinton
which was such a deep and abiding
passion that once somebody says that
she's a good person you just can't hear
him anymore that's fine that's your own
thing you can work that out yourself but
a lot of people don't feel that way they
want somebody that talks the issues that
they care about most people in this
country don't care about politics all
these political comments are is talking
about like what's happening
in the Democratic primary race none of
this matters for at least another few
months nobody's paying attention they're
paying attention oh you know football
just started they're paying attention
they're kids going back to school they
don't care about this stuff so you have
to talk to them about things that they
have a problem with not the things you
have a problem with it's a better way to
go through life if you want to be
successful in sales or politics or
relationships you have two ears and you
have one mouth listen to what concerns
people and speak to their issues don't
go off on what's most important to you
because remember we are the vanguard we
are the Navy SEALs of the Liberty
movement we are the special ones we
think differently were the dreamers were
the mad ones you're special you're
different I'm glad to be in the movement
with all of you but remember not
everybody's awake yet and sometimes the
way to get there is to go gently and
talk to people where they're at and get
them to move just one or two steps
closer to you and that's how we
eventually win
[Applause]
thanks guys we do we go to the Q&A
portion of the program as you know Dave
but you perhaps don't quite know Nick at
this point you can ask each other a
question at any time you can do that now
or you can wait for other questions the
moderator has the prerogative to ask one
of you a question I also want to mention
that we do have seats down here so
anybody who's standing can walk down the
aisle to the front row and take a seat
and I want to start out with moderators
prerogative and asked you this question
Nick Ron Paul was a more strident more
forthright more more vociferous
proponent of ending the Fed and in the
wars then Gary Johnson was or bill weld
was I imagine you agree with that would
you prefer if that were the choice
between Gary Johnson or build well like
candidate for the next presidential
election or a Ron Paul strident
principled and a Fed candidate which one
would you prefer for the next nominee my
preference is going to be for a
candidate who is going to speak in bold
tones about the issues that are not
being addressed by the two old party
nominees every presidential election has
to do with looking at the field that
you're you know the day brought this up
to really unpopular candidates both one
of whom is a reality TV star and the
other one has never had any executive
experience that's part of the reason why
running to chief executives made sense
for that cycle so I think a strident
anti-war candidate who also was for free
trade and open immigration and ending
the national debt or actually like
ratcheting it back those are four issues
that neither the Republican or
Democratic nominee is going to touch and
that gives you a clear Lane to be a real
option right they don't have a
second-best option anymore
if you're a hardcore anti-war voter the
is nothing for you outside the
libertarian party I mean allegedly the
Green Party still exists but I'm not
sure that's the lane we should be in so
I do think that we should be bold about
those things I think we should be a
perfect candidate might be the one
that's boldly anti-war anti war on drugs
anti-war overseas just be against all
war Lee writes who sought the nomination
in 2012 against Gary Johnson his whole
campaign slogan was I am not at war
either at home or overseas
it was strident it was passionate he was
a passionate man he sadly passed away
the delegates didn't choose him they
went for somebody who was able to reach
more people with a softer message and
that's really the delegates choice they
get to decide how to balance that oh you
want to come in there I mean the
question is whether you'd prefer if Ron
Paul had run on the LP ticket in 2016 I
mean I don't know I think you'd have to
be brain-dead to not say yes I don't
know would you have rather had the
country doctor who knew more about
monetary policy and military history
than anybody else in the room who
inspired millions of people to join the
Liberty movement yeah I think I would
have rather had that guy and the idea
that you go oh well if you're an
anti-war voter there was nowhere else to
go except the LP I mean okay yeah you're
right that's how George W Bush won
that's how Barack Obama won
that's how Donald Trump won the truth is
if you are an anti-war voter there was
nowhere to go period and look at Tulsi
Gabbard right now she was the most
googled candidate after both of those
debates and she sucks on every issue
except war and she's getting some
traction off of that obviously the
Libertarian candidate should be the home
for for the anti-war vote and if you're
not if you're not doing that like I said
before what's the point okay no
questions do you want to put two each
other at this moment so we're gonna go
to the winners please phrase you put it
we can put questions okay all right I'll
put a question to Mick so do you think
let me ask you this if you could run a
candidate let's say you could run Dick
Cheney
on the LP and get 10 million votes would
that be a good move like my point my
question is if you could run somebody
who has no you know they want to lower
taxes they want to do a couple things
here but you know they're a war criminal
and they're for torture and all these
other things but you'd get ten million
votes out of it would that be a good
idea me personally because I don't pick
the nominee that's new are misleading
about what they put okay the debate that
we're on pi radians don't pick the
nominee either I'm asking you your
opinion on who the nominee should be
which is what this whole thing is about
no I I think it's a bad bargain I think
Bob Barr was a bad bargain I think that
taking somebody who has too many bad
views because they have a higher profile
that there is a point where you get
diminishing returns right like you have
to balance it if you don't balance it I
consider Dick Cheney to be unbalanced
okay but is in many ways but is it that
he's unbalanced or is your point that
there are certain views that are
disqualifying that if you had this view
that's too much it doesn't matter how
what you think on other things if you're
for torture and wars then it doesn't
matter how many votes we get is that
fair to say
no I just
he's just unbalanced so why not go Dick
Cheney for ten million votes because I
don't think ten million votes is worth
it yeah I don't think four is so four
and a half one more question real quick
do you think there's any issues that you
any positions you could have as an LP
nominee that would be disqualifying that
would be so unliberated that you would
go you should not wait no matter how
many votes you would get we don't
support you being the nominee I'm sure
there are what would they be it's up to
the delegates no for you dude we are
debating for you what would you think
for the nominee so yes exactly
thank you stop being a lawyer stop being
a lawyer this is a good this is a good
tactic it's like the same thing when you
say you know the Mises Institute aren't
fascists but they're the favorite
Institute of fascists this is good
lawyer tactics but it's really cowardly
for an intellectual conversation so what
do you think
this is what we're debating what issues
would be disqualifying to be the nominee
for the LP I think being pro war is
disqualifying so bill weld is
disqualifying no bill Wells not pro war
okay let me okay since since Dave wants
to ask questions I want to ask one to
please
who should we nominate Dave it depends
on who's running should we nominate in
2020 Dave right now I stopped being a
lawyer Dave I've never been a lawyer in
my life so that's not a problem we
should nominate as I said before anybody
who's willing to run an anti-war anti
fed campaign if you were asking me of
the last time or are you asking me no
I'm asking you in 2020 who should we
nominate because you took the
proposition that we should never
nominate and work with views like welder
Johnson that's right so who and what
views should the nominee have they
should I just said I've said this over
and over I will continue to say this at
a bare minimum
they need to be anti-war anti fed I'll
look at who's running right now who's
who are the candidates who have declared
for 2020 I don't know you tell me well I
thought you were the chair of the party
I thought you remember are you not
paying attention to the race you have
strong feelings about who we should
nominate excuse me sir I am a
dues-paying member and from what I
understand from what I've been told
you're the least important member of the
party so I will say listen whoever is
better look I'm not saying any of them
are perfect Austin Peterson would have
been better than Gary Johnson McAfee
would have been better than Gary Johnson
but better than bill weld for sure
Adam khopesh is better than the then
[ __ ] bill weld for sure listen like I
said guys this isn't a joke you know I
know some of you I know there are people
there that are like I'm too radical you
are radical too if you're a libertarian
you're living under the biggest state in
the history of the world in your anti
state you're a radical too we need to
actually take a shot at doing something
here so I would take anybody who is that
I would take a Justin Amash if he ran an
anti-war anti fed campaign like I said
before great answer question please
raise your question as the quest
here's a question for Dave so in 2016
which of the four principal candidates
did you support or vote for are you
asking me what was the question in 2016
who did I vote for yeah I didn't vote if
you listen I'm not I'm not just gonna go
out and vote for something where you
have won whatever I have a hundred
millionth chance of influencing someone
you got to win my vote I'm not gonna
vote for somebody bill weld was
disqualifying for me like I said so I
didn't vote for them so you got trouble
huh so you got trouble so did you yes I
got Trump
we all got Trump your vote didn't change
it any more than me not voting yet are
you suggesting we wouldn't have had
Trump if I had voted for Johnson well
did you think I was gonna make the
difference do do you want to comment
Nick do you want to come into the
question no I think it's pretty clear
who I voted for
because I voted next question so Dave
you talked about the the outside
attacking the middle and we just saw I
think one of the most successful attacks
by the outside of the middle
orchestrated by Steve banning all right
he put his ideas in the Oval Office they
run this country in a lot of ways so my
question is you also seem to not like
that as a strategy you want to make the
million new libertarians versus have a
you know a Rand Paul as the Rand Paul
administration is that actually less
attractive to you then than a million
new libertarians look first off I would
reject the premise that Steve been and
got his views and what happened was
Steve Bannon got a candidate to run on
his views he got in and the war party
took over and Steve Bannon was out a few
weeks later so the idea that Steve
Benton's views are in there is I think
completely inaccurate we haven't pulled
out of one war they haven't I mean
anyway if you're saying would I rather
convert a million people or actually get
someone in there who can kind of shrink
the size of government you know that's
an interesting question
like if let's say Gary Johnson had won
and he was in there and he shrunk the
government by 20% and then the debate
was would you rather convert another
million libertarians or
get in actual but he didn't win he
didn't do anything nothing's been what
has been done with all the Cato
Institute libertarian party money
they've raised nothing what what in the
federal budget has been reduced what's
been abolished nothing so we just lose
either way let's convert a million
people I just noted that Dave didn't
answer the question
what I'm sorry what did I not answer the
question was would you rather convert a
million people or elect somebody like a
Rand Paul who is a moderate libertarian
uh Rand Paul if if I could elect listen
if they think Rand Paul was the example
he used yes if Rand Paul and by the way
I was prepared to vote for Rand Paul
mostly just because he is Ron's son just
but I was but he didn't make it till the
New York primary because he tried to
moderate and failed and if he had run
like his father he would have still been
around in the New York primary like Ron
was and I would have voted for him so I
it's just a false choice that's the
point so yeah if Rand Paul by the way if
someone like that was around I might
have actually voted for him
because unlike Gary Johnson unlike these
other guys Rand Paul actually knows his
stuff and I kind of believed he was you
know deep down somewhat principled next
question hi thanks for the debate
everyone Nick this is a question for you
actually regarding you mentioned how
there's different kinds of libertarians
in the libertarian party I wanted to get
your perspective on the diversity when I
think of diversity the Libertarian Party
I think of non-aggression principle and
I think of the fact that the hapa people
get along with Roderick long people they
all get along with the Sam Konkan people
they all get along with Brian McClanahan
and the and the Confederate people what
I don't think of is lukewarm Republicans
who are frustrated and lukewarm
Democrats who are frustrated feeling
welcome whereas none of these very very
different other people the hoppers the
longs to con Keynes
it's a wide spectrum of libertarians
don't feel welcome anymore do you see
your broad tent libertarianism catering
more to
pseudo Republican pseudo Democrats or to
the intellectual variety within the
libertarian party I mean I appreciate
the spectrum of thought at the Mises
Institute but there is more than that
I'm dubious on hapa but I'll give you
long
I'll give you conch and I'll give you
char da I'll give you block I'll give
you woods Papa Papa maybe a bridge too
far I you know SEK three didn't really
get along with many people near the end
here's the that when I'm talking about
the diversity within the deliberate the
different kinds of libertarians the two
rough groups that I see as party chair
and talking to people at conventions are
there are the property rights based
libertarians the the idea that
everything comes from property and
everything is related to property proper
Terry ins if you will if you won't I
don't care it's I will then there are
the what I would call individual rights
libertarians this is probably most
clearly in people's heads reason
libertarians the idea that the most
important thing is that humans are free
to make as many peaceful choices as they
possibly can in their lives and they're
not as focused on things like money and
property and taxes and covenant
communities and all that other stuff
right there different flavors of
libertarian both sides are libertarian
but because you came at it from a
different premise you have different
platform planks that are more important
to you or less important to you so the
reason libertarians tend to get really
exercised about things like open
immigration and the war on drugs and
over criminalization and discrimination
and systemic racism because those are
related to individuals having the
ability to pursue happiness any way they
choose and the property libertarians are
concerned about wars and money that
funds Wars because it all comes back to
property it all comes back to taxation
as theft and the government shouldn't
take my money to go do bad things to
people overseas right they're both true
and that's the issue that's the problem
with dismissing with coming up on this
stage and saying I would have voted for
Rand Paul but I didn't bother to vote
for Gary Johnson when he was on my
ballot that is the problem if we're
gonna be part of a team we all have to
be on the team together and if part of
the team spends all of their time
talking about how everyone else isn't
really a team member that's a problem
okay so I'm not saying listen like I
said I'm a soldier in the Liberty
movement I want more than anything to be
part of a team look like so many of you
guys I miss the Ron Paul days I miss the
days when we had a leader and I could
just be like yes I'm behind you but that
whole mentality of I'm just part of a
team is why there's Democrats and
Republicans I mean is there any
principle where there's a point where
you go no I'm sorry I can't be a part of
that team and now the idea that there
are these some libertarians who believe
in property rights and these other who
are just kind of individual rights well
no one of them have a solid of
philosophical framework and one of them
don't I mean even when you just said
that they go well some just believe that
you should be able to do whatever you
want to that makes you happy well what
if robbing someone else makes you happy
as long as I seems like a liberal don't
mistake my position you know no I'm
quoting what you just said no you're
saying okay anyway I don't know what to
say
Hans Hermann hop is a hero Lew Rockwell
zaheer I'll have the courage to say it
libertarian movement wouldn't exist
without those guys so long live both of
them next question next question first
question is to the audience who here
hosts a lucrative podcast because my
wife and I host a podcast that is very
lucrative at a grand total of two
dollars and 67 cents on YouTube so thank
you
I've been on that podcast it's very good
wait what's your part watch new podcast
what's happening because we're half
Asians so anyway Nick I wanted to know
what you personally is your number one
issue not just what the party puts up
the way you personally and I already
know what Dave is gonna answer cuz
because he says anti-war all the time
its podcast is like 24/7 yeah and gamma
Nana give yo it's like we get it you
know I'm kidding I'm kidding I love your
podcast anyway so yeah what's your
number one issue you personally my
personal number one issue and the thing
that even when I was running a municipal
race for mayor of Phoenix almost
everything comes back to the
criminalization and the war on drugs and
part of it has to do with my lived
experience having been a public defender
for five years seeing how the system is
built to in Carson eight or incarcerate
and destroy communities seeing that
every erosion of our privacy rights of
our Liberty right so the right to search
and seizure every expansion of the
police state every cop who murders
somebody all comes back to the war on
drugs so criminal justice reform in the
war on drugs like I mean I'll I will
throw myself under the bus if you had
Dick Cheney and he ran only on the
platform of legalized all the drugs and
end the racist war on drugs across the
country I would vote for him at
Convention whoa hold on let me jump on
that please jump on a load of first
world privilege you just threw at us so
you would take killing a million Iraqis
if we could end the war on drugs here at
home do you have any evidence that they
aren't gonna kill a million Iraqis
anyway because they have for the last 4
administration's yeah every other
politician that gets elected is gonna do
sound that war okay so you're saying
Dick Cheney
mister [ __ ] carpet bomb the Middle
East mister Institute torture you would
take that cuz really it's just those
poor Muslims over there
as long as we can end up by the way
we're all against the war on drugs Arwen
obvious yes okay what are we no you're
right you got me I'm really for the war
on drugs Nick oh man good lawyering
there okay
yes we're all against the war on drugs
but the number one issue that everyone
should be thinking about that look man
there is a genocide happening in Yemen
right now and I know I talked about on
my podcast all the time because it's a
goddamn genocide if you look at what
we've done to Iraq Libya Syria Yemen
you know five or six other countries
this is this is I mean it's on the level
of Hitler or Stalin it's the most evil
thing that's going on right now and to
say that you would take Dick Cheney
somebody who can't go to certain
countries because they'll be tried for
war crimes that if there was any justice
in the world would be put on trial and
executed after it is just that's crazy
that the libertarian Chairman would say
that and I'll to and to say that you'll
accept what we've done to Baltimore in
New Orleans in Chicago no one's and your
and Washington DC and that you wouldn't
take the end of the incarceration of
generations of african-american men
because you think foreign policies more
important go ahead we don't way to go on
no one said that I didn't say I would
take a drug warrior if he would end the
wars I said I wouldn't take Dick Cheney
to end the drug war you guys were here
for that part right Cheney would end the
wars would you allow him would you vote
for him if he said he was gonna get us
out of all the overseas wars he if Dick
Cheney wasn't Dick Cheney I might like
him he's not ending the war on drugs
either so I think we're both safe next
question this is gonna be directed
towards Nick um I believe is in your
opening you said that the point the
Libertarian Party is not to promote one
single issue the point of the
Libertarian Party is not to educate
people to become libertarians the point
of the libertarian party is to win
elections okay but what's I don't agree
so in elections the point of the
Libertarian Party is to bring about a
libertarian future so because of that
wouldn't you have to say that educating
people and getting a million more
activists that can bring about that
libertarian future instead of just
getting one candidates who can get 10
million
one year don't you think it's more
important to educate them educate these
activists I'd like to answer in gift
form if possible why not both um the the
the goal of the latter
I would tell Nick not to quit his day
job if I didn't really really really
want him to quit his day job the goal of
the Libertarian Party as stated in the
mission statement is to move public
policy in a libertarian direction by
running candidates for office running
candidates for office and getting them
elected is only one piece of the puzzle
there are two issues in the last 50
years the Libertarian Party has been in
front of and gotten effectively passed
in these United States marriage equality
and cannabis legalization we're the only
party that's been for it we've been for
it for decades and it's the law of the
land and we did it without having a
single federal office holder because
what happens is if you keep running
candidates who refuse to shut up about
the important issues that move us to a
freer society you forced the old party
party politicians to co-opt them all of
a sudden in 20 what 13 14 the Democrats
all sort of got religion they're like oh
yeah we totally supported marriage
equality the whole time don't worry
about it like yeah sure I mean maybe you
saw me on TV when I was running Hillary
Clinton and Barack Obama both talking
about marriage being between a man and
woman but I've changed they didn't
change cuz they wanted to they changed
because we've been pushing that window
so you're right it's not just about
getting people elected but if you don't
go out and rack up the score they don't
take you seriously that's the point
that's how we move the ball down the
field we refuse to shut up about these
issues we force them to take our
positions or start losing elections
that's the only language politicians
speak and if we don't use that weapon at
our disposal we are doing a disservice
to our movement all right I think what's
doing a disservice to our movement is to
pretend that our movement achieved mayor
decriminalization and gay marriage that
was the left they won just like they'd
won everything else in this country and
to pretend that we did that oh that's
right California legalized pot because
they're so libertarian out in California
that's where they listen we may have
been on the right side of that issue
before the left came and changed the
country but that was the left man and no
one in the real world is gonna believe
you that the Libertarian Party is the
reason why any of that happened listen
the left has won at just about
everything to pretend that we're it's a
disservice to our movement to pretend
we're not losing look at the federal
spending every year look at the I mean
come on man like we're losing everything
no one has bought into the principle of
small government the Republicans used to
talk about it and not believe in it and
now they just stop talking about it
we are losing and let's get real just as
a factual correction because they still
don't care about Dave's feelings the
libertarian party of Colorado of which I
was vice-chair in 2012 when we were the
first state in the country to real
eagle-eyes cannabis was the only
political party in the state of Colorado
that backed amendment 64 which got more
votes than the sitting president in
Colorado so it may be true for
California it may be true for other
places but for Colorado we were at the
forefront of it we were the ones in the
trenches fighting and we did get it done
okay I'm not saying that the libertarian
party didn't support the right position
I'm saying it wasn't you who got it done
and you can keep borrowing Ben Shapiro's
[ __ ] stupid line I just could you
said could you stop borrowing his
foreign policy also
yes sir
hi this question is directed at Nick you
made the argument that mm that it would
be difficult to gain more followers or
gain more libertarian members because
people feel free and if you walk out and
you ask people if they feel free they'll
say yes I just wanted to ask like do you
do you think about like the people that
support the blacklivesmatter movement do
you think they would answer that do you
think the people that think that Trump
is literally Hitler would say that they
feel free right now or how about the
people in the middle of America who see
all these politicians saying that they
want to take away their guns like do you
think that they're free and like they're
not we're not gonna be able to convince
them that they have an issue with
freedom no I think those are the three
groups and just to pick three groups
those are the groups that we can reach
the this is basic sales stuff right this
this goes across relationships sales
everything but politics too you can't
get somebody to buy something you're
selling until they're convinced that
they have a problem if they're happy
with where they are if they don't have
any pain you can't fix the pain so yes
the black lives matter people we did a
lot of outreach so they occupy people
when that was a big thing Libertarian
Party members went to go speak to the
Tea Party protests we're currently
ramping up some gun rights stuff because
the NRA is busy exploding itself with
corruption we are hitting those issues
where we see people who have woken up to
the fact that there is an area of their
life where the government is is hurting
them is taking away their freedom and
it's important to them the way this
works is we go to that person and say
you know what we agree with you the
racist cops are killing too many black
people this is a problem we want to work
together to solve this problem and by
the way you might want to check out the
rest of the libertarian party platform
while you're here and some of them will
yeah it's what we do is we go and make
the point that tapes takes absolutely no
courage to make at this point more or
less that's what that's that's what this
is the the idea that look first off you
know it's really something for me to get
lectured on how we expand the Liberty
movement how we convince people exactly
how we go and approach them by said
you're the chair of the LP I'm some
comic I've converted way more people to
the Liberty movement than you have I
have no I mean look I'm not saying I'm
like the end-all be-all or anything like
that but I've way more of an audience
way more people know who I am play again
I know I'm coming off a little bit
hostile in this debate and part of this
is because I'm very passionate and I'm
an [ __ ] and part of this is because
he's like insulted some people who I
really love and like basically imply
that they were like Nazis and fascists
and I'm you know I'm the Jewish grandson
of a Holocaust survivor so when people
imply somebody's a fascist or a Nazi for
political gain it really pisses me off
so I'm I'm sorry because I'm kind of
coming off like a dick here but to be
charged it here's how you convince
people okay you believe in something
even when it takes you into unpopular
opinions you stick with it because you
go this is what I believe in and when
you're Gary Johnson and they go oh I
want to end the war on drugs and someone
goes but you want to legalize heroin oh
not heroin no one cares
because you're when you go oh but not
freedom of association because then
people will be racist or whatever anyway
that's how you convert people believe in
something don't ever apologize for who
you are Dave don't ever apologize next
question okay yeah I think you guys are
both great and I think you both have
legitimate points of view that are not
actually mutually exclusive but you're
the last okay this is the last question
okay you know I support a lot of what
the Libertarian Party stands for but
here's my question how can the
Libertarian Party call itself the party
that's anti-war both at home and abroad
what you guys as a party oppose any form
of gun control how many people need to
die in a Walmart or a school before you
guys change your minds
oh lady listen you know what she had
some courage in that one so I'm not
gonna die all right listen I I will
absolutely support all of us turning
over all of our guns to the government
as soon as we run a background check on
the government and make sure that
they're not a threat to kill people with
those guys okay so I just I want to be
very careful you know I believe in
background checks so as soon as I'm sure
that they're not gonna you know like
genocide 250 million people in the 20th
century will let the government have a
monopoly on guns it can if you'll
indulge me thank you for the question I
think this illustrates something you
asked a very sincere question about an
issue that's very important to you and
you just got booed by a roomful
libertarians and and did that make you
feel good or not all the sudden feelings
are very important now I want there to
be less gun violence in this country
the problem with gun violence in this
country comes back to the war on drugs
if drug dealers were like alcohol
distributors and could go to court when
they had disputes and didn't have to use
violence there would be less demand for
guns
if we were in less wars overseas there
would be less soldiers coming back with
PTSD there would be less glorification
of the military there would be less
violence in our society the violence
problem is not a gun problem and the
number of guns that are out there and
most of the proposals would not work so
I agree with you that there's a problem
but I don't agree that the fact that we
are hardcore against any gun control
means that we don't that we're not
anti-war we're anti violence because we
don't like the vile
but it's not the gun that does the
violence thank you I just want to
mention to the young lady that the sole
form did have a debate on guns which
introduced a lot of nuances and issues
that haven't been raised even by our to
articulate people on this stage and so
you might want to check it that out go
into the soul formed org I think it'd be
a very interesting debate which raises
questions and issues that maybe you
haven't quite anticipated thank you for
the question it was very bold I don't
really think anybody food I think they
were just very impressed it was no
beating it was a new no not a bleed and
well again we are now going to go to the
final segment of the debate summary
statements Dave you're up first
all right well you know I don't really
know exactly how to sum this up and I
don't want to just repeat myself from
the beginning look I know I know there's
some of you who think that I'm too
radical or you just don't like my style
or whatever and I get that I'm not
running to be a national candidate for
the LP I'm just talking to us frankly
about where we are you know Nick can say
this stuff about um you know the way you
convert people is well you have two ears
and only one mouth I don't even know
what this means
convert people by standing for something
and believing in something what Nick
isn't addressing is that like after oh
they got all these votes for Gary
Johnson what does that do this is what I
was getting at when I asked him the
question would there be any issue that
you would say is disqualifying and then
he falls back to this like well I don't
pick the candidate because he doesn't
want to admit it because then he knows
he's giving up the argument if you do
acknowledge that there's some issues
that are disqualifying then obviously
being pro war and pro fed are those
issues that's it that's I'm not I don't
have some purity test that's all I'm
saying
we should at least before that so okay
Gary Johnson got
four million votes or whatever they got
15,000 dues-paying members it's pathetic
it's pathetic
they had double that when Harry Brown
was the nominee and what they didn't
have a lot of votes but they had double
that because they had a candidate who
had some principles that's all I'm
arguing now what's not been addressed
throughout this whole debate is what I
started with which is the most important
thing guys we got to realize what
situation were in I'm not being
hyperbolic when I say this country's on
a suicide mission do you guys not look
around and see what's happening right
now the debt the wars the regulation the
prison industrial complex the
militarization of the police and now
after the state's been growing and
growing and growing for my entire life
in very dramatic ways I mean George W
Bush grew the state faster than any
other president before him and then
Obama did more than him and now we're
living in this Trump and you see the
country tearing apart look I talked
about this in my comedy special do you
have you ever heard of a country that
was a republic that turned into an
empire that got way too expanded
militarily spend itself way too far into
debt then the culture started falling
apart and everyone got divided and
everything worked out okay you ever
heard of that before you think I'm being
hyperbolic when I say we're on a suicide
mission right now we have the answers
and we have to actually go for it well
you know this idea of like a couple of
well there was a good time to elect a
couple of governors because Hillary
didn't have executive experience and
Trump didn't have exec oh my god talk
about missing the point it was the time
to go for it 2016 doesn't every
libertarian wish we had a chance that we
could actually have the world like a
stage where a lot of people were looking
and explained to them what we are and we
had that now the reason I care about
this so much is that we're gonna have it
again in 2020 because Donald Trump is
gonna be the nominee
it's not gonna be your loyal bill weld
who left you guys high and dry it's
gonna be Donald Trump and it's gonna be
some terrible Democrat Joe Biden or
Elizabeth Warren or whoever it's gonna
be a terrible Democrat verse Donald
Trump and once again the Libertarian
Party is gonna be there and I really
think man we
try to nominate somebody who's anti-war
anti fed will stand on principles can
actually get people up out of their feet
motivate people look our only chance is
to convert more people to libertarianism
now I I know nickel tell you this is how
we convert people to it I don't think
he's right
how many people isn't it converted to
libertarianism I don't think that many
what Nick is done is really hurt the
Liberty movement she is alienated Tom
woods Ron Paul the Mises Institute the
people who are the most effective at
converting people bringing them into the
Liberty movement why would you go why is
it that if I bring up bill weld he'll
just dance around and say every nice
thing you can say but if Ron Paul comes
up or Tom woods comes up he's talking
about have they're like we're retweeting
things that they're Russian spies or
they're crypto-fascist this is insane
like what are we doing I want there to
be a Liberty movement I don't want us to
be in this internal war but we got to do
it by being libertarians and letting the
chips fall where they may as the great
Tom wood said enough putting people to
sleep already it's time to finally wake
them up thank you guys
most people in this country don't know
who Dave Smith is they don't know who
Tom woods is they don't know what the
Mises Institute is hell they don't even
know what the Cato Institute is they
don't know what reason magazine is
whether you want to acknowledge it or
not whether or not you come in to this
debate with a pre-selected set of
notions and uh you know you're gonna
you're gonna vote how you're gonna vote
no matter what I want you to leave here
understanding we are different and we
often live in a bubble we don't talk to
people who are not like us which is a
natural human trait
we need to run candidates who can appeal
to Americans who can appeal to New
Yorkers who can appeal to Arizonans who
can appeal to your neighbors your
co-workers your friends the other people
in your classes and they have different
needs and different desires than we do
there are different things that make
them passionate than we have Dave said
something just now that doesn't make
sense he said I don't have any purity
tests the candidate just has to be
anti-war an anti Fed those are purity
tests those are litmus tests those are
you saying that everything is important
but this is more important than
everything else and that's true for Dave
and for somebody who whose brother is in
prison for drugs it's the drug war
that's the one thing that the candidate
can't do and for someone who really
loves guns it's gun control as the one
thing the candidate can
- there is many purity tests as there
are libertarians which is why it's not a
dodge for me to say that the delegates
choose the nominee the party is made up
of those who show up it's made up of
Libertarian Party members and I would
encourage every one of you whether you
like me hate me or have no particular
opinion about me other than you know I
have bad taste and ties or something to
join the Libertarian Party visit LP org
join the party stand up be counted be
part of that conversation this is a
conversation that we will have in Austin
Texas our party is the only political
party in this country that still has a
real nomination process
no one knows before the convention who
the nominee is gonna be as opposed to my
colleagues and the other parties I don't
put my thumb on the scale I don't have
any influence over who the nominee is
I don't do backroom deals I don't pre
select people I don't spike Bernie
Sanders to elevate Hillary Clinton the
Libertarian Party is made up of you if
you want to be part of this but it's
time for people who have spent a long
time throwing rocks from the sidelines
and talking about what they want but
then not being bothered to even go out
and vote for a Libertarian Party
candidate to join the party get involved
in the party at the local level support
a candidate go to a fundraiser give some
money work a pole talk about a candidate
have them on your show do the things
that you can do to advance the people
who go out and run the last thing I want
to talk about because I touched on it
but I didn't really sink at home in
December of 2016 the Libertarian Party
had ballot access in 37 states that is
the highest number we've ever had Gary
Johnson did that for us Gary Johnson did
that for us and what that means is every
candidate up and down the ballot was
able to run in those midterm elections
in 2018 we were able to run hundreds
instead of tens or 20s
this is a long term movement our party
is poised to be the first part
in modern history to have back-to-back
50 state ballot access and it's because
of Gary Johnson so while I didn't hear
what views we ought to have or what
views were so disqualifying I do know
that he did something for this party
that nobody including Rampal has ever
been able to do and I appreciate that
and I don't know if he's right about
everything and there are a lot of
mistakes that were made on that campaign
but those people did something that no
one else has ever been able to do for
the Libertarian Party and I can't argue
with those results I can't throw rocks
against people who are out in the arena
getting beaten up on TV all the time
going and spending the days and the time
to fight for us I will support them and
I hope that you will vote for the
negative proposition thank you well
thank you both for impassioned
articulate debating either of you I
think could be a candidate on the
Libertarian Party ticket and you might
each consider running and possibly
together but
yes possibly yes and I think we are all
proud to have both of these guys feel so
impatient about issues that we care
about with that said with that said
however we have opened the voting Jane
you've opened the voting for the final
vote again the resolution reads the
Libertarian Party should never again put
up national candidates whose views are
similar to those of Gary Johnson and
bill weld yes no or undecided while
you're deliberating I do want to
announce what I know I told Nick and
also that Dave is aware of there will be
a after party fundraiser sponsored by
Michael highs of a Mises caucus after
the debate and that will be held at the
loft apartment of me and my wife Masako
if we've already sold tickets to it if
you want to buy a ticket
Michael hice is over there the white
he'll give you the address and he will
sell you a ticket a Nick saw walk you
are comped if you would like to come and
so great yeah great and so come up to me
I'll give you the address it's so we
keep that a bit of a secret are in
addition addition not please come again
to the Sola forum if you look at our
roster we have ten debate scheduled to
the end of the year and through early
next our next debate will be October 7th
Jakes Jacob solemn will be debating drug
use which came up today and Jacob seller
mode will be defending a resolution
about ending the war on drugs against
New York Times reporter Alex Berenson
Dave we hope you'll accept the demotion
and come back and come back as a warm-up
act
I got a baby I need that money okay yeah
so Dave will be returning as warm-up act
for the Monday October 7th debate on
drug use on November 5th Tuesday
November 5th Richard Wolffe University
of Professor Emeritus eken of economics
will defend a resolution about socialism
and he will be debating me are the guest
moderator will be yes right away will be
Nick Gillespie I do want to mention I
debated Baskar Sankara I was trying to
help get an older guy that time I
approached Vivek shipper who had been
Bosco's debate mate learned some
economics Bhaskar that's what I did
but Bhaskar is only 28 29 i I kind of
sent it to him a little bit but now now
I am going to be debating the guy who
has been called Richard Wolff has been
called the best socialist economy in the
country
he's written guys come on oh you're
friends okay be friends afterwards at
the party any case I will finally have a
guy in the room who's been an emeritus
professor who's written copiously on
socialism who takes a strong position on
the subject who is the expert in the
country and socialism
unlike Bhaskar who was a bit of an
amateur so this will be I think a very
worthy debate between me and professor
Richard Wolffe I will also mention oddly
that that our sister debating society
intelligence squared has decided to have
Richard wolf and Bhaskar debating in mid
November on the issue of of capitalism
and I fear I fear that that debate is
once again going to be this kind of
dispute idea that capitalism will be on
trial Richard and Bhaskar will get a
chance to compare capitalism with their
vaguely formulated notions of utopia and
nobody will ever ask them
as socialism all about my debate is
going to be about socialism is
preferable to capitalism so Richard will
have to define what he means my
socialism I have indeed read his copious
work I know what he means by socialism
and I can tell you what he means which I
will do during the debate on Sunday
December 8th we're going to have a
matinee that's going to be 3 p.m. on
Sunday if our very first experiment in a
matinee Loyola University professor of
economics waterblock will defend his
evacuate is is it fiction as a fiction
theory of abortion we are still going to
invite Dave Smith as the walk back
even though Dave was gonna be the guy
who was gonna debate Walter plot but I
decided not to have Dave do that so he's
gonna be debating instead Carrie Baldwin
of the MIR Liberty podcast defending his
theory of of eviction with respect to
abortion Jane I think we have the final
vote and I want to say that the Tootsie
Roll will finally be distributed to over
Wednesday today okay so we had 40 40 %
supporting the resolution initially that
that Dave was defending and that rose to
60% so Dave picked up 20 points that's
the number to beat Nick you did
extremely well except you picked up 16.8
points you went up from 14 to 31 so you
did quite well but Dave gets the Toshiro
you